John let me start with a poll question
Jeter LeBron or Brady whose career
can I go off the board sure
Jordan speith Jordan speith well this is
more like who I'd want to be Oh
I mean like 21 years 20 years old
whatever winning the money knowing
you're going to make gazillions of
dollars playing golf most your days I'm
good with that
all right stay with the poll question
then Jeter LeBron or Brady whose career
here man
more more off the field stuff I would
say it's probably the probably put me
over the top
i-i'll of the picture of the infield
with all the ladies that are in right
left field Center I mean he can't do
better than that
did you at least have an infield John oh
uh I would call a bride a dugout they
never made them field well yeah I would
never want to be out of a field in
public I mean if we stay in the dugout
you know I try to raise my high you know
it out there all right explain to me how
the Spurs get that big leave explain to
me how they blow that big lead well
surprising I mean look we saw him in
Game six they look like one of the
greatest teams ever against the Rockets
smoking them by 40 or whatever it was
without Kawhi Leonard so you know very
surprised that they could collapse like
that having what getting outscored 5833
look I understand how great Kauai is and
that kind of bolsters is you know stance
on being an MVP of how great this guy is
but a crushing loss I mean you know I
don't know what happens in Game two if
he plays but I I'm shocked that they
could lose a lead like that as good as
they were playing and it was not all
Kawhi Leonard Aldridge played well not a
Ginobili played well again
everybody was pitching in and he goes
out and they just completely lose lose
their minds it was it was stunning but
if I look at that play on Kawhi Leonard
with Pachulia how often does that happen
normally in a game and do you think it
was out of the ordinary it was not a
dirty play I have seen people
intentionally get their foot in there no
question about it but that play in
particular I don't think it was dirty
czaja contested the shot and he actually
just turned his head and looked to see
if he had to go in for the rebound so I
don't think there was any ill intent on
the play at all but there is there has
been instances where guys will put a
foot down and hope the guy comes down on
it we don't see it a ton but it's
definitely a tactic that I seen some
players in the league use the Warriors
screens get a lot of attention if you
want to call them screens there's
there's some hmm kind of grabbing that
goes on there's sort of a a knee or a
leg or a hip or how would you describe
the Golden State Warriors screams
everybody does it if we sat here and
called moving screens the games were
last for five hours I mean there's
always some movement on a screen when
you're putting yourself out there you
want to protect yourself - you're not
going to let a guy just run you run
right into you into your stomach so you
might put it a little elbow you might
dip your shoulder you might get your
knee out there everybody does it
everybody grabs they're just good at it
and you know they move so quickly and
they're so fluent maybe you know the
officials just don't don't see it I
don't know but everybody does the same
thing but they do it pretty masterfully
and and what they do is they sort of
screen in transition so it's not your
typical pick-and-roll it's just sort of
I'm going to get in your way just a
little bit and then that frees up Durant
or curry for jumpers yeah the officials
not really looking for that you know in
transition you know they're worried
about running down the court they're
probably looking at the basketball we're
looking straight ahead where they're
running so yeah you don't anticipate
screens in transition but when they get
on a run
I mean it is it is so beautiful to watch
when they go on in 1820 Oh run I saw it
again to Portland earlier in the
playoffs I mean it's it is so fun to
watch for their offenses explosions he's
John Barry of the mothership he'll have
the call he's the analyst for ESPN Radio
tonight game seven starts at 8:00
Eastern on ESPN Radio what do you expect
to happen and give me a scenario other
than the Celtics win at home how does
that happen for the Wizards
well no idea I mean this has been a
crazy series you can go back to every
game in this in this Celtic wizard
season the home team is won every time
ten in a row so you don't know
Washington has to bring their defense
they've given up over 120 in every
single game here in Boston in the
playoffs they tell them the 95 when
they're in Washington so for whatever
the reason the defense doesn't travel
for the Wizards it's got to travel
tonight they can't afford to give up
that many points and you know typically
in these games it comes down to who can
be a hero you know can it be Otto Porter
can it be Gortat or Morris you know
could it be Crowder or Bradley or mere
Johnson who knows but somebody else has
to step up you assume that Isiah Thomas
will play well Bradley's play great
Horford you soon Bradley Beal and John
Wall will play well who's going to be
that third guy or maybe even the fourth
guy to get it done it's John Wall great
player I think he is I think he had a
great season I put him just behind Isiah
Thomas and my MVP voting Heat when he I
don't know that there's anybody faster
going to the rim than him when he makes
a decision from end to end he's as quick
as there isn't a leak he doesn't shoot
it great but he's much better better
than he's been III think he's a great
leader I think he truly cares about
winning I don't don't think he cares
about numbers uh yeah I think he's a
great player if you could have him for
the next five years or James Harden
oh that's uh that's a good one um and I
guess I got to go with hardened I mean
29 and 11 that's that's tough to up to
snub your snub you're you don't seem
like you're all in on that though uh I
think it's a discussion yeah i reaiiy
really do but I mean you know James
Harden is a guy wins a game offensively
on his own I don't know that John Wall
does that he's capable he had a 40-point
game in this series but that's not
really what he's about true scoring and
hardens been able to show the ability to
do both does that take away anything
from an MVP like season what happened in
the last quarter game maybe six quarters
for James Harden in the previous series
well it's not going to matter since
we've all voted but that certainly
leaves a bad taste and I'm still trying
to wrap my head around what happened
there he hadn't had a game like that all
season and to take two shots in the
first half of an elimination game and
just bow out that way I I think that
there has to be something that's
transpired in the locker room or off the
court to see an effort like that from
that team yeah I didn't understand the
game plan when he didn't have a shot in
the first quarter and then I realized he
only had two in the first half and I
went I does he not know who he's playing
with that they they're not going to
survive this way and all of a sudden
goes down in flames and fouls out and
they get blown out and I don't know that
you're right there's a mystery there
maybe maybe something comes out here
eventually in the offseason I and Kawhi
Leonard goes out you think that he would
take just completely take control you go
back to the games five that offense in
the in the overtime period was as bad as
I've ever seen I mean it was James
Harden holding the ball till about the
five-second mark and then chucking up a
shot yeah bizarre we'll have fun tonight
play nice as always and we'll talk to
you again
thank you okay all right that's John
Barry ESPN radio analyst
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience